coming to you from Los Angeles
California the show where people turn
for intelligent conversation on all the
topics you care about I'm Evan I'm
Gareth and this is point versus point
and we are back point versus point a lot
a lot of juicy news to get to this week
but before we get too deep in the weeds
I want to apologize for last week oh you
should have as for last week as as of
those as those of you who listen to
remember I accidentally ate way too many
md MDMA pills um and you know the truth
is I was I was just trying to teach
Gareth a lesson you wake her praising
his drug use you know lately it back you
know that you got show do you know that
you got naked and twerked I um do you
know what that's like for me to have to
what that's my doll or Siam to walk i'm
gonna be that i got regular sometimes
having flashbacks of just seeing you new
delete work I was uh house in Maui so
how was a man all wrong but this show
does not advocate drug use okay then now
with this shows or theft and that's why
I want to apologize to our audience okay
this isn't this isn't a druggie show you
owe me three hundred I'm not for those
pill i'm not paying you any money ok i
will you i will take it i will take you
to court over time you've stolen so much
of my money over the course borrow
borrow gareth we threw a wedding that
you had me pay for and then you canceled
it okay oh I'm sorry that I got to hold
feet you know do you know what it's like
to be a bride and waiting you had my
emotions all Alyssa the point is I have
a very very big announcement you're
getting gender reassignment surgery
finally off the champagne everybody he's
fine okay um it's even it's even bigger
than that okay this show point versus
point is now being carried on all things
comedy ok this is this is big news okay
so i wanna i want to welcome all the
future p
that are listening right now that we're
happy to have you the fans have been
very clear that they're not on board
with that people like poor thang I think
the people like being called P heads I I
what why why is this on a comedy network
you know I was a little confused by that
too obviously this is a new show for
those of you who are listening for the
first time this is a new show it's not a
comedy show it's where people turn for
intelligent conversation on all the
topics you carry right up um so so you
did it is it's surprising to me the only
thing that's really funny about the show
is how bad it is ironic way the show is
fun okay um well I I agree that you know
maybe a more appropriate home would be
all things new you're all you know [ __ ]
mmm it doesn't matter okay the point is
there are a whole lot of new potential p
heads out there and we should start
filling their heads with Pete oh that's
can't put that back in the bottle why do
you have an igloo cooler with you oh I
don't worry about it what's inside
what's inside there's just some snacks
to get through the show snacks to get
through the show yep let me see that let
me open the cooler no let me see what's
inside the cooler let's start the
goddamn show fine you're such a diva
this is the big story
tell me a story right now go shower pic
big store Trump and Kasich neck and neck
in Ohio Trump leads in Florida in
Florida home state senator marco rubio
has been trying to get traction against
Trump but still trails Ted Cruz has
overtaken Rubio in Florida in Illinois
Trump also leads thirty-eight percent to
thirty-four percent over Cruz who is in
striking distance with Kasich back at
sixteen percent the findings across the
three states may suggest Cruz is
emerging more generally in the minds of
many non Trump voters as an alternative
to the front-runner um and you have you
know what I'm gonna say but I am excited
I mean political season was it is it's
getting wet hot it's getting wet hot ok
let's careful let em hear excited let's
be careful because sometimes the
language you use is very insinuated when
you're just talking about these things
ok yeah well that's just because i'm not
i'm not trying to insinuate anything
except for that i am titillated because
this is this is good stuff going on you
know this election cycle right well
great I'm glad that you're really happy
about this yeah I mean look I look I
love the drama I mean it's a real-life
opera and the stakes couldn't be higher
fit this may be a good time actually you
know that that you you bring up a good
point you know saying that you're you
you like you love election season and
you love it because of the high drama
I'd love it because of the drama right
and the pageantry all right you know
there's a lot of pageantry ok dominates
shut up when they're when all those
candidates are on toys and and they're
just there one of them one of them's
like oh no you have a date actors ma'am
I shall see the proposal of it that's
what I love ok my point being that maybe
this is a good opportunity for us to
expand tell the people a little bit
about ourselves so we're starting you
know so so your name's evan is not a
time you love telling no no no because
there's some quirks that i think would
be fun for people to see the new atc
audience to hear you know some of this
rather just stick to the story that may
receive a new show Evan wears a bra it's
a chest apparatus okay but it is I mean
it looks it looks identical to a broth
of course it does it's made of the same
material and it has snap yeah welcome
test apparatus
man if it walks like a bit men I don't
know if you know this men traditionally
don't wear bras okay well yeah and
neither do I bro yes your chest
apparatus I'm just saying if it's made
of the same material it has snaps if it
looks like a bra and it talks like a bra
in my beer bro we don't need to rehash
this okay I'd rather stick to stick the
news okay which is right now we're
talking about the election we're not
talking about the fact that occasionally
when it gets very humid out I have a you
know some lactation issues with you know
I wasn't even gonna bring that up people
might be eating well that's why I'm
wearing the chest apparatus it's okay I
thought you wanted to spend is
seasonably humid okay but it's not it's
this isn't a big deal and I don't mind I
don't mind talking about what are you
what do you are you eating soup why are
you eating soup right now lentil oh that
is delicious uh I'll tell you I have
quite I have quite the appetite you pee
sitting down that's another thing right
yes okay oh yeah a lot of guys pissing
down right okay and I don't mind it's
gonna be connected it's until you bring
it up like it's like this think it's
this bad thing like I should be
embarrassed guys guys pee sitting down
all the time no they don't realize guys
do not wear bras all the time and they
don't be sitting down all the time a lot
of thinking you have admitted maybe you
pee sitting down because you have micro
penis I did you revealed recently on the
show no no I do not have what would be
technically defined as micro penis what
can you has a very specific thing look I
have it I have what is it was a whole
range of normal Gareth in a whole lot of
difference is normal about you because
if you really think about it a lot of
right you want you practice a dark
religion you pee sitting down I do not
I'm you you have micro penis that's now
to have doorly to have leaky tip nipples
I mean okay oh my gosh you sound so
silly I don't have leaky tip nipples
okay what I I have a little bit of a
lactation issue that started at puberty
okay and it just is first you will know
I want it Gareth can't we just talk
about that why are you eating soup right
now the show is a half hour long
quit I quit doing drugs and I have an
appetite you should understand tit boy
can we just move on I just want to move
on to the next I'm ready to move on I
wanted right I i'm down to not do the
show yes I know that ok ok all right ok
but but since we are doing the show
maybe we could talk about the stories
what's going on in the election the
election is page 6 boobies don't call me
boobies ok don't call me boobies and if
you do want to call me boobies whatever
because you know what I'm not I'm not
I'm not hiding you know I'm here I'm out
in the open ok you know warts and all ok
and uh you know if you want it if you
want to make fun of me because I pee
sitting down or because I may or may not
have what is a scientifically considered
micropenis you know like fine laugh it
up ok but I'm over here just being me ok
being confident me because I feel good
and I'm proud of Who I am ok ok sister
preach on the bridge store Trump rally
chaos Donald Trump's campaign on Friday
postponed a rally in Chicago amid fights
between supporters and demonstrators
protests in the streets and concerns
that the environment at the event was no
longer safe the announcement which came
amid large protests both inside and
outside the event at the University of
Illinois at Chicago follows heightened
concerns about violence in general at
the GOP frontrunner rallies Illinois
holds its Republican primary on Tuesday
hundreds of demonstrators packed into an
arena breaking out into protest even
before Trump had shown up at least five
sections in the arena were filled with
protesters now I think that this this is
truly a scary story I mean things have
gotten out of control and Trump is a
fear mongerer okay there's another
reason why Trump has my support hey he's
smart dude campaign events are boring
mosh pits are awesome do the math okay
there there is no reason none okay to
root for chaos no one's rooting for
chaos what also I am
is that good TV and I just remind you
and Jerry spreads like Jerry Springer
presidential [ __ ] you might want to
watch what you're saying because we have
a new audience now you're talking about
supporting Trump and he's clearly racist
can you talk about what being a member
of the KKK which then we found out was a
kesha's kind nights or something i don't
i don't even remember but but it you
just want to be careful okay because
it's people could get the wrong idea
okay well we should remind everybody
that you are the liberal media and that
you have these positions that you just
hold because you know again I mean you
practice a dark religion you are you are
part of the liberal media now you have
admitted that you wanted as much as
Obama's dick I'm voting you know and
that's a quote you said you say to go
doubt of context Garrett you said on Air
that you would suck it out of context
well okay the point is stop eating what
why can't I combine my work and my play
is that a chicken sandwich why are you
eating a chicken sandwich chicken salad
sandwich with chicken salad sandwich
this show is only a half hour long how
come you cannot wait till the end of the
show to you by hiding during every story
dude dude dude I can't help that since
I've been clean ish I my appetizer come
back full force that's not on me I'm
eating like a pregnant lady not i love
it i think it might be possible that
you're just replacing one addiction with
another can't be addicted to eating food
dumbass put that put the chicken salad
sandwich down why just put it down put
down for ten seconds what was it like I
dare ya no I just wanted to you dare me
to put down enjoyed it down Sam what
again don't eat the chicken salad
sandwich I'm tracker yeah cool families
down get pad great okay all right now
sure yeah okay know that that was
intense act that was close to ten
seconds no I'll just write it down you
can't stop eating look I can't help it
that it feels good running through my
[ __ ] veins dude okay get back to the
story if you show I mean whatever you
know what fine I do i do want to get
back to the story okay because uh
because because of violence is never the
right way to express yourself okay
that that's just what people who aren't
smart and want to engage in in healthy
dialogue ah oh just throw an ashtray in
my head an accident how did you
accidentally throw an ashtray in my head
slipped out of my hand I was trying to
move it and it slipped and I fell over
there Jesus Christ Gareth what you know
what this is the perfect example of
someone reverting to violence because
they don't have the skills to express
those not talk to me like that I do have
the skill strict but why don't you guys
throw an ashtray at my head that's it oh
don't tell me that I don't know how to
express myself like violence why did you
just smack me across the fakirs I'm did
that your words hurt me your words hurt
me okay when you say when you say that I
can't express myself without using
violence that hurts me well that proves
my point is that if you see the face i'm
gonna punch you in the [ __ ] mouth I
know how do you ask myself keep it on
silent give me get your [ __ ] it no
get out US Secretary of State John Kerry
has called for the resumption of Syria
peace talks Monday in Geneva following
meeting with Francis new foreign
minister and other senior European
diplomats Foreign Minister jean-marc
Ayrault hosted Sunday's meeting in Paris
which also included the British German
and Italian counterparts and the
European Union's foreign policy chief
the meeting comes ahead of un-sponsored
indirect peace talks on syria which are
scheduled to start monday in geneva amid
a two-week partial ceasefire that has
mostly held we look forward to the
resumption of talks in Geneva on Monday
Kerry said in a joint news conference
with his counterparts John Kerry has a
weird head and face that that isn't a
take on the news okay that's just that's
just a petty observation I'm just saying
he looked like he looks like the kid
from the mask if he was in the you know
this is such a strange time in America
you know I mean you you almost have
trouble focusing on the world you know
but Syria
still this huge problem and it needs to
get dealt with okay you know I mean
that's part of the problem I think I
think we as Americans we've become so I
work what we're recording in hero
actually that's prime I grubhub order
why sorry yeah I ordered some grub can
you Gareth is just there you go you
watch that game oh now you watching it
now I'm doing this [ __ ] stupid
podcast unfortunately i wish i'm
recording it but yeah yeah can we um
sorry Kim can we just yeah thanks for
coming over all its have fun thanks bro
do you know that guy huh do you know
that guy yea he's the grub hub delivery
guy okay yeah i mean he's over here a
lot right he delivers the grub why why
did you get did you have to get grub up
in the middle of the show I'm hungry
dude I can't help it you know what I
mean I had look it's not it's not my
fault that I had a hankering for Indian
and a pizza let me explain to the
audience what's going on oh why don't
you explain to the audience what's going
on the the last few weeks um as a lot of
you hopefully will remember Gareth has
had some issues certainly with with
drugs you've been down at all you've
been tail spinning yeah paint a lot of
different you know just anything
anything that could potentially they say
what's the one you always forget about
right and and this is the stems back
from a few weeks ago Gareth had a movie
a pitch called the the United States of
Kevin okay hashtag it was ok I'm sure
everybody knows of the project shirt
this was this was a movie about a
twelve-year-old eleven-year-old g11 your
wife's boy that gets elected president I
what I hear it back yeah you like just
like Wi-Fi and I guess it had a little
bit of traction a lot of traction I
wouldn't know a proponent of us had buzz
I've had by right that's what you kept
saying you were shouting that the buzz
has buzzed but the truth is that it was
in actuality was actually just seven
pages the script the screenplay was
seven pages and somewhere between 2000
and 4000 magazine clippings and you took
it you took a pictures yeah yeah
pictures magazine clippings from
attitude yeah yeah and and you had a
deal set up of Warner Brothers
potentially and they passed on it I
think probably after seeing the script
right or wouldn't you know what isn't I
don't need a script that but when you're
going polish I magazines are in a very
captivating order it's a very compelling
order there's an evolution you your
little brain is ways whereas your that
magazine clippings is way too many mine
and sent ages is not enough so you know
you're way off on a lot of that I think
just the measurements with a you know
anyway who care the point is the point
is since then you've been out of control
okay and instead of doing drugs this
week now you're eating your feelings
okay and it's not healthy it's equally
unhealthy so you're saying i go back to
drugs all right no okay you know what I
don't even wanna I could kick Here I am
again right down the rabbit hole ok I
want to talk about Syria let's get Syria
about Syria well I don't sorry I
actually I normally I'm not the one who
makes jokes like that about really
serious issue that that's really all I
want to apologize Oh super fun no no
well um I want let's get back to let's
talk about no but I you're gonna have to
an issue okay apology choose of Syria
and we are we are newsman here at PvP
okay are a newsman and you know what I
can't help I can't help picture what
what a president Trump would be like in
these international situations what do
you I mean you know could you uh we
don't need Syria let's build a wall you
know well what the actual [ __ ] was that
just now what what don't please don't
tell me that's what I think that it was
I've been kind of work shopping a Donald
Trump impression it's awful yeah
literally not I don't do it I probably
shouldn't have done it but I was just I
was a little
way oh I would love to hear it a little
more no it is working out rain it's like
we are we don't need we don't mmm we
don't need cereal I think it's sounding
a little bit like Bill Cosby it's so no
it sounds like you it sounds like you're
doing a you impression the point is who
does impressions of themselves that's
not what Trump I'm not like at all okay
but here let me add but let me ask
president Trump a question just as let's
work the impression muscle sure okay
president Trump are you excited to ride
on Air Force One for the first time the
polls say that I am excited for are you
trying to do something or you just need
are you this is the really early stage
of this impression okay I think I broke
it out a little too relations what are
you gonna go on SNL I just have a radio
I think it's just it's fun and
especially now that we're on all things
comedy I want to like be able to have a
mixed bag Evan Evan stop I speak for
everybody when I say do not try to
entertain or be funny or engaging you
you are here to read story you're right
I'd shut your mouth right that way
that's not that that's not actually I'm
here for analysis no no that is not
people care about my analysis of the
news we're recording no no dude that's
that don't say we're recording that's my
e24 brother you also got eat24 I'm
hungry ass the e 24 and the grub hub guy
are the same guy I want to apologize to
the audience right now this is not i
mean it is you know the show the show
doesn't mean sometimes we actually do
get into issues and we talk about what's
going on in the world and I know that's
what the P heads want to hear and Gareth
hey can you guys wrap it up
let me get an application from you like
next time you come by oh okay good to
see you again man I later bruh you're
gonna get an application from him that
dude is chill as look that dudes awesome
all right anyway who are we talking
about Oh egg rolls right mm-hmm um what
do you got okay great so so you keep
eating food ah I'm sorry that I had a
hankering for pie and clams right pardon
my french okay and you also brought a
cooler and you've had two delivery
orders through the course of a half hour
show would seem strange really strange
Garrett it doesn't seem any more strange
than being a micropenis bra wearing
sitting pisser okay let's move on okay
so now is the part of the show where we
let Gareth kind of take over or hijack
the show for a minute this is hijack
esterases no Evan don't try to sandbag
Garrett's the best part of the show I
would love to welcome the new audience
to Gareth stern Jesse Nogueira's turn is
the delicious tasty yummy meat that is
wedged in the middle of this [ __ ] bread
sandwich that is pvp this is Gareth's
turn Garrett's turn Garrett's turn it's
my turn now baby I'm coming at you it's
my turn it's garrett turn Garrett's turn
Garrett's turn its history
stand here it's my turn it's Karis turn
turn turn turn it is my turn turn turn
turn alrighty i want to welcome
everybody my turn i already welcomed
everyone ivan i demand silent from your
time I don't I in silence for me because
this is my turn now I think it's
important that the new listeners know a
little bit about what garras turn is
like and about Gareth and we already
know some stuff about Evan and it's
dramatic but I want to let the fans know
that I the new listeners know I am the
fan favorite we've all I I didn't ask
for that title I was you I would shut
your mouth boy I was given that title
because of the connection I have with
the fans I mean if it's it's it's
blatantly obvious if you look at my
twitter I've way more followers than
evan and it's because i love to hear
from the fans and I'll another I love
the fans and the fans love me and that
that's just the way it's been from
inception it's what some are calling a
two-way love highway because it goes
both ways who's saying that who's saying
it's a to label this is my turn silence
it is being said now where was I oh yes
why am I the fan favorite nobody is
saying that your science me boy silence
silence boy don't okay me you are a boy
sent you to town with never the reason
why I'm the fan favorite is because I I
the fans know that I'm here for them and
that I will always listen to them and I
communicate with them because they are
my favorite thing the fans are like a
drug for me and you know how i get with
drugs actually speaking of drugs i'm
gonna have a little hit of this mushroom
balti don't mind if I do oh you smell
that what is your turn about this week
what is your turn Evan I'm in the middle
of my turn okay the fans will have to
excuse Evan you see evan is jealous of
the connection that i share with the
fans so we really think about it Evans
anger while it's it's there it comes
from not being able to experience the
high from the fans now Evan Evan
and this is this is medically diagnosed
by a doctor a black heart that's but
that doesn't even make sense okay and
what are you doing what is your turn
about you you you you can shout at me
oven but you you will admit that you you
haven't admitted that you do practice
the dark religion I'm Jewish ah there it
is an admission okay now fans ignore
Evan and now in summation summation what
are you summarizing what would have you
done what did you turn about in
summation Gareth good funny smart
attractive fast on his feet loves the
fans loves and I'm gonna get emotional
here loves the fins and fin and pins
love me back
okay just look at the twitter hashtag
fan favorite guess whose face pops up
that's Garrett and evan has a black
heart and probably has a book of spells
so okay good good okay i'm glad that on
our maiden voyage in the atcs it has
zero to do with issues and freely about
you just shouting about how great you
are okay that's I'm glad that actually
makes sense hashtag fan favorite look it
up guess whose face you see and now it's
time for everybody's favorite segment
it's time for new z- not losing huggin
easy nugget nugget nugget newsy negatory
'he's i just want to explain what this
segment is it's just it's just a little
fun stroll to the lighter side of the
news okay so strap on your lap belt and
prepare for some turbulence because
things are about to get nutty I my guess
is that we don't need to explain to
people that your voice gets very strange
during this part of the show my voice is
my voice gets totally cool no because if
you don't see what you're doing they
would see that you have this sort of
your head moves and you kind of have
this dumb meeting I know your problem is
you haven't put on your lap belt okay so
strap it on because it's time for new Z
nuggets nuts first newsy nugget
Norwegian man rides snowmobile on water
for 131 miles a Norwegian daredevil set
out to break an unusual world record
when he took his snowmobile for a 131
mile trip on the surface of a river a
video posted to YouTube by Yann Helmer
Olsen shows daredevil Morton Bleen
taking his blares RM Kia 800 snowmobile
for a four-hour drive that last year on
the waters of the carjack and tana river
in finnmark norway Bleen made it a
distance of 130 1.7 miles before his
snowmobile suffered mechanical failure
and ended up submerged in the river
Oh Olson said lean fell short of his
goal 152 miles but bested the world
record of 112 miles which was set by
auntie holmberg why are you what why why
do you do what are these people doing
what I mean snowmobiles snowmobiles are
made for the snow not water I mean this
guy this guy must have thought the water
was way colder than it was I mean hey
hey are you water or you snow Oh what is
it uh-uh hey there's no way and this guy
up stop stop what is happening dude I
figured you Tucker yourself out but it
seems like you're revved up it's nearly
naked you're what you're it's an easy
[ __ ] stop stop okay all right I'll
admit that this is really overdoing it
isn't it isn't the nuttiest story okay
but i want the be edge I want them to
feel my enthusiasm I really want to I
really want to fill their heads with P
then okay first of all and that you said
that's the same time you said that it
sounds like you want to pee and I want
them to know the enthusiastic I don't
think we should I wanted to know the
enthusiasm that I have for nutty nuggets
okay yeah okay but but okay let's let's
say this now that the podcast is on a TC
this might be the best time to stop
doing newsy nuggets all together I mean
it doesn't work maybe it's time to bury
it are you kidding me no I'm totally
I've never been more serious what yeah
it it's not good the show itself is bad
but this is this is Tara doing new see
nuggets not yes Xena its admit you want
to stop yeah I might never happen that
never craziest thing I've ever heard
what that would be like going to a movie
and not ordering popcorn I mean there
would be like a wedding without cake
then be like going to the beach without
a metal detector I mean what are you
talking about Gareth no new z- knits
that's what this show is people love
this segment is everybody's favorite
segment I
say it in the title of the segment no
Evan you've told yourself that and it's
not true what would nobody likes you on
the show you're not good on the show
okay you're awkward okay you know right
where you're not good tag fan favorite
thank you for a thank you for promoting
murder although I a while meanwhile
people may remember I'm hashtag king of
the show I know I know a lot of people
haven't your you know it hasn't been
trending recently but I don't [ __ ]
you're in my turn you're in okay you're
an idiot you're a delusional idiot I
mean I say and I think I'm being soft
we're not gonna stop doing newsy nuggets
nuts the P heads want newsy nuggets nay
I don't like and I'm gonna give them
musi- nuts okay they love being called p
heads okay okay okay great yeah okay
fine I just think that it's not good and
it could be replaced easily replaced
okay replace with what what would we
literally anything else anything else
honestly we could just have dogs bark
that would be but you actually we could
expand Garrett's turn that everybody
loves Garrett's turn that segment is
like a nine-to-five job as a team or
segment what is what did you do this
week I mean I caught people up on me and
what I am to the fans and what the fans
are to me again Evan you wouldn't
understand you have a book of spells you
have a black heart a doctor told you
that you admitted it I'm never that's
that never happened on the show just for
the record um okay I see what you're
doing you're trying to rattle me you're
trying to make me upset what we're not
do you live where you think I would
enjoy rattling you we're and I'm just
trying to make the show as good as it
can be though it's terrible okay well
I'm trying to make the show as good as
it can be to that I know we're not
getting rid of nizzi maggots have nits
yes boobs are big business for Russian
messaging startup titty gram while the
financial crisis has hit many of
Russia's entrepreneurs hard the founders
of messaging startup titty Graham are
seeing business boom the service
launched in 20 in spring of 2015 allows
customers to send a virtual card with a
greeting or any other message written on
a chest male or female you select your
favorite model online and send the text
of your future message as soon as an
hour later you will receive a photo card
that you consent as a gift to a friend
mmm ok now I've heard everything Chitti
Graham titty cram I do you know what a
story like this does Gareth this this
shows the people this shows the P heads
what's inside my nuts okay fun okay and
my knots they're full of fun and and
this is my way of letting the listeners
just get it does he had a taste of my
nuts okay and now that they've had a
little nibble okay they probably want to
put all of the nuts in there I haven't
stopped good God stop what why do I have
to keep stopping you going these rants
it's insanity I'm doing neezy make it
look this might here's the news here's
the news flash this might be good news
for you because you have tits I don't
have tits okay I look I don't want to do
this okay I just want to do newsy
nuggets serious I'm serious you really
you could make some scratch here right
you could just you could you mean think
about your dragon those knockers around
in that bra of years all the time it's
not a bra it's a test apparatus okay and
they're not tits look a one I was
younger I had a minor minor ailment okay
which a lot and I mean a lot of guys
have okay and yeah my nipples you know
are a little bit bigger okay and there's
um there's some skin tissue pocket where
with it just tits no it's known sorry
mm-hmm sorry bro not gonna take the bait
take the bacon you have titties they're
they're not I just thought this was a
fun story okay and I wanted people case
my story but i also think within this
there's maybe a way to make some money
off of those milk makers and start our
own titty graham thing no sorry we could
just maybe make a little scratch off
your jacket pumpkins stop stop making
tit synonyms okay i'm not that's not
what I'm try to do I'm just you know I'm
just saying that you know you could make
money but if you want me to be done i
will stop referring to your t-shirt
tatas or your watery bra maracas or your
hairy up front bumps or your junks I'm
done okay i want to thank our wonderful
producer Vicky peza and of course
Hollywood Dave to pee
true yeah we got LP in the place tonight
I'll do yeah we have L dog here uh who i
want to i want to thank for being here
as well this is actually a good show
this is a good show a people who are
listening for this first time this is a
this is a good show and we do we do you
know we do cover the issues and we I
know it didn't happen tonight but we
would you know if you're if you're
interested for intelligent conversation
and all the topics that people care
about this is the place for you right
yeah you know and the truth is let's say
people don't listen and people don't
like it that's also good no that's
because that's every good news that
stopped the nightmare okay and end this
I mean just like hell
you